welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki episode 4
rewrote the timeline logic of the mcu
once again not only by revealing the
timekeepers as robot puppets of some big
bad we're all probably theorizing wrong
but that proney loki actually teleports
him to some mysterious
exile that were not for the new york
skyline really shares more eccentric old
people makeshift weapons and loose
gators with my homeland of florida
except in florida the gator would get
elected president now we actually began
discussing this episode 4 post credits
scene
in yesterday's rogue theory i highly
suggest you watch it some really cool
ideas brought up there
and unfortunately i wasn't able to join
it because i was working on the
breakdown when they shot it and tommy
and i are variants of each other that
might fall in love and break the
timeline
but here i want to dig even deeper into
this post-credit scene to explain
what this exile is exactly who these
other loki's are
what really happens when you get pruned
and other huge clues that we can get
based on the remaining trailer footage
that has not been in episodes yet okay
so after getting pruned in the back by
rent slayer loki wakes up thinking he's
in hell with one l the norse mythology
hell but instead he's greeted by four
other loki variants you've got classic
loki that's played by richard e grant
boastful loki played by diobia
porre kid loki played by jack veal and
what i'm calling loki gator
played by a fella you'd find on a
jacksonville golf course being wrestled
by a really angry retiree who's been
snowmaning it all afternoon
but here they appear to be in the ruins
of new york with avengers tower visible
behind them but as i pointed out in the
breakdown this is probably not
new york immediately after the battle of
new york in the first avengers film like
some 2012 timeline where loki won or
iron man failed to divert the nuke
because avengers towers top floors now
have the added top floor quinjet landing
pad
that was not yet built into it in 2012
but it did not appear until 2015's age
of ultron also remember that this tower
was later renovated again
sometime after avengers end game because
in spider-man park from home set in
summer 2024 the tower was reconstructed
with an atrium that
is not visible here but taking a closer
look at each of these variants
classic loki's attire is the bright
yellow and green costume with huge horns
worn by
loki in the early comics he carries a
messenger bag and after seeing wanda
envision in their classic comic getups
and wandovitch and i just love that
these disney plus series are finding
ways to make these throwbacks meanwhile
boastful loki seems to be dressed up in
loki's dark rain attire with the first
shoulders and the ringed belt
he carries a makeshift mjolnir that is
made out of a piston
shaft and a chunk of a train rail now
kid loki in the comics
shows up after the destruction of asgard
when loki is reborn as a child in paris
with at first no memory but then has his
soul partially restored and just stays
in this young body and then gator loki
loca gator by the way not a crocodile
they do teach us in florida public
schools a difference alligators have the
rounded snouts crocodiles have the
pointed snouts anyway this guy
might have come from a timeline in which
thor was a frog named
throg which is an actual series in the
comics that was referenced in thor
ragnarok sorry about that time i
turned you into a frog now based on the
trailer footage this seems to be part of
a setting where there is a president
loki in a ragtag band who all turn on
him
all of these guys might be other variant
loki's and here it seems like this loki
might have a chance to put together his
own loki squad of avengers because the
framing of loki sitting up here
looking up at a lineup of oddballs
leaning over him it exactly matches the
shot from the avengers and the music
even samples silvestri's avengers theme
[Music]
but really the question is why was loki
teleported here
instead of being erased from existence
now if you like what we do here at new
rockstars one of the best ways you can
support that content and help us do more
is to grab some cool swag from
newrockstarsmerch.com our partners at
epic hero shop have put together a full
lineup of really cool gear
shirts hats hoodies water bottles all
kinds of stuff to make your friends your
family co-workers fellow arby's diners
jealous we also have our limited edition
latest obsession
shirt line right now the loki out of
time shirt is inspired by the loki
disney plush show the supply
is limited so you gotta act fast we've
already sold out of the xl and green and
a bunch of the red sizes but when you
buy a latest obsession shirt you
unlock the ability to leave a shout out
that will appear on screen during our
weekly inside marvel episodes and you
can finally tell grandma how much you
care
via a youtube video the epic hero shop
has a massive
all original loki collection with other
shirt designs stickers even a miss
minutes wall clock check it out in
all of the other merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
you'll be helping our channel while also
earning major
nerd cred loki's destiny in the sacred
timeline is to
lose to die at the hands of thanos now i
say
in the sacred timeline when really i
think we're about to find out that that
timeline
is only sacred to whoever's really
running the tva some mystery figure who
wants and needs loki to fail
so that the god of mischief won't
chaotically interfere with
his selfishly precious timeline and this
show is refuting that argument that
loki's are destined to fail
do you think that what makes a loki a
loki is the fact that we're destined to
lose
no we may lose but we don't die we
survive
yes survival resurrection that maddening
whack-a-mole essence of loki
is exactly what makes him so dangerous
both in the comics and in the mcu
and i think that's why loki variants
like silvi were targeted despite
not really creating any nexus events in
that moment it's because loki's have
this special affinity to cheat
death and as we saw in the comics they
reincarnate they respawn
in a way loki did this in the dark world
but the one exception to that
was when loki encountered thanos an
eternal titan
armed with the power stone and the space
stone who after killing loki infinity
war specifically said
no resurrections this time and when loki
watched his death back in episode one
that was the end of the tape now
remember that death occurred in 2018
right before thanos would snap and dust
half of all life and leave new york in
the state of chaos
and then as a depressed ghost town so
perhaps when loki variants are pruned
they
could be exiled to that point
specifically because that would begin
the point in the timeline when sacred
timeline loki is no longer alive
and then the variant loki's get trapped
here unable to respawn
after thanos says no resurrections
declaration
and maybe the various loki sent here
could have taken over this area and
skewed it into their own branch timeline
battleground where the tva is like good
stay there but there is a creepier
explanation that
pruning variants could trap them in a
kind of snow globe
pocket reality like the san diego snow
globe on rinslayer's shelf and there was
another snow globe over on the side
there too
similar to that new york snow globe
mysterio trapped spider-man in
or the chronopolis bubble kingdom in
which kang collects
trophy pieces of the histories that he
has conquered that might explain why new
york looks the way it does here
not completely flattened by a nuke or
occupied by alien invaders but just kind
of quaked
off its axis a bit actually trailer
footage
shows the sudden drop in of the uss
eldridge 173
a ship famous for the philadelphia
experiment conspiracy theory that
suggested that the ship was rendered
invisible by a cloaking device
perhaps this is another relic along with
the polybius arcade game
collected as a trophy in this little
bubble meanwhile other promo footage
shows mobius driving past the sphinx and
pyramids of giza
but not in a desert terrain in a similar
grassy terrain like these other
landmarks are in
mobius could be an exiled variant
trapped in the same place
trying to make contact with loki and i
will note that pyramids were
among kang's collection in chronopolis
now in the alternate angle of loki's
arrival point from the trailer the area
around them looks cleared out
like maybe other loki's camp around this
respawn point ready to pounce on
whatever new variant pops up
also notice that in that shot loki
stands alone whereas here he is
surrounded
meaning that we could see another loki
respawning here but ultimately whoever
runs the tva clearly hates loki's in
particular but
might refrain from killing them because
doing so would allow them to respawn in
another form
but pruning them traps them in this
prison exile with
other bickery loki's all unable to
respawn and escape
instead stuck with each other and going
mad we will find out exactly where this
is going next episode but meantime he
can support new rock stars by checking
out our merch options including our loki
inspired shirt loki out of time
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars and thank
you for watching bye
[Music]
you